j'accueille jean marie bigard
après le stade de france un peu un peu
ridicule ici non non non c'est toujours
bon à prendre
ouais même les petites quantités c'est
cette qualité qui compte
vers 6 en maille alors j'y tiens lancé
dans cette émission il ya deux semaines
mais vous avez été retenus au brésil
jean marie bigard à cause de l'opération
de votre épouse
oui il ya à qui vous avez offert de
nouveaux saints absolument
et comme il vaut mieux faire mieux
s'adresser à dieu qu'à ses saints est
donc allé voir le dieu des saints ouais
c'est bien le professeur peter guilbaud
pitanguy ivo pitanguy qui est une star
qui a un peu l'inventeur du procédé
1 et lui il a une technique à lui c'est
que il fait des saints identique
ces bris à la même hauteur et ça marche
très fort ça plaît beaucoup
donc dès qu'on veut plus voir des
charlots ça va quand même mieux quoi oui
parce que votre famille en france s'il
avait fait des salariés un an et demi
avec un sur l'épaule et pilates
donc c'est un peu un nom là ça va
beaucoup mieux on est très content on
sort du cauchemar quand
alors à part les cinq crises à d'autres
d'autres actes eu quand même des gars il
ya une bd dont vous êtes le héros
il ya le théâtre où vous avez joué
molière sur scène il y à votre nouveau
spectacle le 15 septembre 2006
oui qui s'appelle mon psy va bien oui
alors à commencer par la bd si tu veux
alors transformé en héros de bande
dessinée d'où le titre les aventures de
bigard alors vous vous êtes l'auteur ce
qui veut dire que c'est une
autobiographie d'une certaine façon non
rouaix mais avec des tas de trucs tu
vois par exemple la pierre avant la
pierre était grossièrement taillées en
bois je suis un homme préhistorique
[ __ ] de silex de merde toit très
grossièrement taillées les vols de la
pierre polie
bonjour madame lapierre est ce que vous
pourriez passer tout un tas de trucs
comme ça
donc le dessinateur c'est clair 1 oui
jacky clech jacques hcc publié chez chez
jungle
alors on retrouve 40 saynètes qui lui
ouvre un petit peu vos thèmes de
prédilection qui sont ouais ça tourne
toujours un peu autour de ça tu vois il
y en a par exemple j'ai mis j'ai mis ma
femme je suis au lit avec boeuf amaldi
en baisse de moins en moins souvent et
ça dure de moins en moins longtemps
qu'ils devraient consulter
je vais voir un psy en fait je nie club
si je reviens dit alors cherry s'est
bien passée ta séance jean ont comme
avec toi nelson de yabassi aussi et on
attrape des maillots de bain et 12 les
trucs il ya pierre palmade ya tony
glande il tient ya guy carlier quand
même oui à guy carrier de d'enfin jacky
s'est amusé à mettre comme ça des
copains et 200 roule plus vite les coups
évident que les couilles plein ça c'est
dans le bois de boulogne actuelle mais
quels écueils plein il ay l'avant
circuler regarder de bd gay l'hélico
ibid haïti afin toi et entra maison
royale chérie ma femme qui me dit chérie
je voudrais un orgasme au lycée vont
peut-être déjà eu un sac à main
cunnilingus c'est du latin et là je lui
propose de lui apprendre le grec
éventuellement pour toi je me par
exemple ces deux fameux truc que j'ai
trouvée avant faut les écarter le
maillot pour voir les fesses et puis
maintenant il faut écarter les fesses
pour voir ça permet de dessiner plein de
belles petites gonzesses dont je dis pas
qu'on va s'astiquer sur le bouquin mais
c'est agréable à regarder
il le vend bien ça coûte cher et ben
écoute ses marques et derrière si tu
achètes cette passe à la caisse elle est
derrière toi merci même pas marqué le
prix mais c'est pas cher ouais
c'est pas cher j'ai construit ma patrie
non c'est super raisonnable ouais donc
ça c'est la première chose qui à l'heure
après il ya quand même le théâtre
ah oui alors ça c'est la première fois
que vous allez jouer j'en avais des gars
dans une pièce de théâtre à partir du 19
janvier
c'est au théâtre de paris avec catherine
arditi grégori baquet dans une mise en
scène d'alain saxe oui donc le pire
c'est que ce monsieur jourdain directeur
de magasin d'articles de sport tente de
s'imposer dans le milieu de la mode
ultra fixé à quoi et c'est ça le compte
en fait est un jet setteur à lui né tu
vois il vient avec une copine qui a
encore un peu de pognon mais il veut que
la nuque et il veut que ça moi je là je
suis comme un lapin dans les phares
d'une bagnole mais j on fait un
bourgeois à droite c'est le bon choix
qu'on a vu en 4e à l'école toit sert on
voit un gros balourd qui s'est tu vois
travailler par tout le monde public son
fric et tout le monde est assez content
et en fait les vrais méchants c'est
quand même ce qui lui piquent sont venus
rhin en fait il est il est plus naïve le
soleil il est plus naïfs les plus
émouvants et eux ils
il a de l'autorité tout est là il a fait
ses magasins toi papa d'en faire un gros
gros balourd absolue et droits de la
franchise
ouais et de temps en temps au lieu des
quelque chose l'intérêt c'est celle à la
performance il devient complètement il
ya un enfant quoi donc il y les plus
émouvants il ya des passages c'est
l'adulte aperçoit de la richesse et du
grand chef-d'oeuvre qui est ce beau
jardin tient parce que on en est plein
de bons joueurs si l on en croise plein
tous les mecs qui est pété de tunes qui
a réussi dans le truc il veut rentrer la
jet set il veut faire la petite par tous
après avoir tapé deux trois rails dans
un loft voix superbe rochelle il veut
accéder à ce à quoi alors après jean le
poulain jacques charon louis seigner
c'est pas évident même de reprendre le
bourgeois gentilhomme non mais tu vois
par exemple l'âge j'ai accepté d'abord
il m'a dit est ce que tu veux faire le
beau joe gentilhomme j'ai dit bien sûr
que non et africa humains comme bien
expliqué j'ai dit oui parce que je ris
que l'aventuré était une vraie aventure
ce ne sera pas un bourgeois gentilhomme
de plus le seul homme risque de faire
date
on risque
de faire ingurgiter aux gosses beaucoup
plus gaccio way et surtout j'ai pas le
sentiment de art
[ __ ] j'ai cru que ça viendrait jamais
sans coca cola jean mary seela pas sans
qu'aucun je les fais parce que justement
tout le monde attend au coin du bois toi
moi j'ai pas besoin de faire ça tu
imagines bien je le fais pour le plaisir
des yeux ronds montre cette aventure
pour que ces mesures ne rapportera rien
tu dis ça à chaque fois au stade de
france et a dit je suis passionné
nous on gagne et elle est que les dvd
mais avec le spectacle sa passion
l'animé le sait de vence cogedim ont
séché et je savais tu es toi oui je
savais avant le stade de france qu'à la
sortie
j'aurai deux millions trois cent mille
euros dans le cul et alla donc faut les
vendre 300 milles dvd pour revenir à jeu
c'est la vraie vérité et pour ça il y
avait un prix de places a été refait
euros on est à 600 milles
[ __ ] il est nourri l'adresse ces trucs
qui marchent plus las vegas ma jambe non
je voulais te finir disant si j'ai
accepté de le faire c'est que j'y viens
pas chier sur le tapis de la
comédie-française francs les gens de la
gauche française s'y feront très
certainement pas vouloir faire ce second
gentilhomme avec des costumes et
costumes on va être drôle
j'arrive avec l'équipe du jour toi déjà
toi j'ai un palm pour donner l'addition
elle a fallu changer les objets sont
drôles les costumes sont extraordinaires
pascale bordet fait des costumes j'ai un
maxi manteaux qui est ouvert jusqu'au
milieu du dos j'ai à mama maxi manteaux
tous un petit peu serré un peu thierry
mugler tout va avec des cravates pas
possible une casquette anglaise une
petite mèche de cheveux à oui c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que et après
faut s'accrocher parce qu'après fall
envoyé le texte c'est à la virgule
appelez ça te plaît pas mais c'est vous
tirez vous donc madame diantre soit la
coquine
ouais tu vois je vous je vous prie tous
deux 2 nouveaux points en aller qu'on ne
m'ait apporter mon habit afin que vous
me puissiez va voir toi là c'est à
chaque fois le verbe il à la fin et tout
alors finalement commandes atteint il
faut essayer de le dérouler à et de
l'apprendre de savoir vraiment vraiment
au rasoir pour pouvoir le balancer comme
ça et quand ça le fait ça le fait
vraiment grave et on y arrive un petit à
petit on y arrive et on a fait un fils h
cet après midi coup tu es bon on l'avait
oublié le texte on s'en foutait on voit
bien qu'on mène tout le temps le verbe à
la fin que toi j'aimerais que vous je
voudrais que vous la puissiez un peu
ragaillardir alors il faut que tu te
mets et ça passe on oublie et on voit
une situation tout à fait moderne ça ça
va être
si on y arrive ça va être épatant et
alors il ya la musique de lully qui a
été réorchestrée r'n'b et hip hop c'est
bien mais alors les danseurs font des
performances est incroyable ça va
rafraîchir très très sérieusement ce
bourgeois quoi c'est le 19 janvier dans
qu'au théâtre de paris
mise en scène d'alain saxe oui mais
catherine arditi et grégori baquet
voilà voilà alors
ça c'est fait ça c'était on a fait la
délais on l'avait déjà fait le bourgeois
j'ai hâte de faire le con maintenant
avec les autres